mr. Chang we're gonna watch the birds of
prey trailer today hey whoa
bars alright guys I'm excited to check
this out
finally getting an official trailer and
this movie is only a few months away
just in time to play before jokers
screenings which we got our tickets for
so make sure to look out for our review
let's swing on an action now shall we be
on the trailer
[Music]
[Music]
not being held down by another man
[Music]
[Music]
it's musical
[Music]
[Music]
- looks great
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
your back girl right
I feel like this movie should have been
called Harley Quinn and the emancipation
of the birds of prey
Harley Quinn Harley Quinn and the other
characters have barely been expounded
upon in any of this effort I was looking
forward to this trailer to see more of
the birds of prey
yes characters you know Huntress Black
Canary and so on and you know you get
better do you better look sad you do and
don't get me wrong Margot Robbie looks
great yeah troll she looks awesome and
you know the screenwriter to talk about
how she wanted to reinvent Harley Quinn
for this movie it seems like a lot of
what her character is dealing with is
finding her own solo identity not being
dependent on mr. J so much you know and
and I like that approach and it seems
like what they hinted at with going on
with black masks that you know he wants
to keep her under under his thumb as
well but she won't have it so bunch of
male characters are gonna come together
to take down the bed evil male white
dude yeah it's perfect you know I never
liked it
Harley Quinn has often been like an
empowerment icon so it makes a lot of
sense here especially in the now like as
long as it's taken I feel like now is a
good moment for this kind of movie to be
here absolutely and I love the tone of
it you know it feels more akin to the
b-roll footage that was first released a
while ago it kind of has a bit of those
like an apparent of vibes to it well
yeah I mean it looks like to me it looks
like it has some of those elements of
like a crime epic the same way that not
does not that it looks like Joker but
the same way that Joker seems to be
borrowing from crime films even with
that music you know it kind of reminded
me of that and then you have just this
other completely garish action-oriented
side and I'm interested
to see how those collide with each other
yeah I think the cinematography looks
great too I love the framing of so much
of where they mount the cameras and a
lot of these is a unique spot John Jesus
freaking button is the throne awful
don't litter yeah you know you blame the
phone or blame yourself which one leads
to growth which one leads to growth for
keeps
I think the cinematography in this looks
like even like weird shots like one day
and it's moving on the cameras mounted
on the card and you got this like POV
shot ever yeah I got imagined that the
visual style has to be really poppy and
kinetic for this because you know like
we're in the mind of somebody who is
zany and insane to a degree and so that
leaves you a lot of room I feel like
within the overall tone of this movie to
really go off-road and some of the
action shots seem like the route of a
kung fu film yeah especially with her
crash zooms and whatnot yeah yeah was
like hothead like flip shots and stuff
and it was that chance to house key
who's nuts she jumped on cuz it looked a
lot like him and I know a bunch of yeah
I know Chad but I know he came in an
inch did a bunch of reshoots for action
sequences and I had that looks like him
yeah perhaps it could be never be cool
for him but honestly I really do wish we
we got more of the birds of prey the
rest of them you know yeah I want to see
more of Black Canary I want to see more
of Huntress I want to get their senses
in ensemble yeah yeah because this
really does feel like oh yeah they're
here too yeah the way this trailer did I
know for your first official trailer
it's good to establish your your main
vocal character as your lead of this
ensemble he's just never been a mystery
true you know preferred for this
particular film like Margot Robbie has
been the selling point the entire time
so yeah you know I yeah it totally makes
sense to have her be the centerpiece of
this trailer but it would be nice to get
a better sense for if this is gonna be
an ensemble if they are just gonna be
supporting characters who help out when
it's time to fight or something
they should be main characters I mean
there I don't every birds-of-prey comic
I managed to read in the past few plants
today have any hardly quitted there but
these other people I wonder about from
birds-of-prey fan not that anybody I
think would be upset about the inclusion
of Harlequin but the direct spotlight
has commanded overall this the other
thing about this this trailer though
that surprised me that isn't a surprise
I just wasn't thinking about it is I
love the fantastical sets and stuff
because even though this does have some
elements that look like they're
borrowing from a more realistic crime
movie and also I love that contrast
because it does look like it's in a
comic book world you've got these
eccentric hallways and lights and these
you know I imagine because of black mass
there's gonna be some kind of show
element to this too and I'm excited to
see where that comes out too
I have a girl looks like he's having a
total blast yeah I love his American
accent that he has yeah he just sounds
so straight-laced yeah which I was like
it's from a different era I know I know
I know and though we didn't we didn't
really get any victors that has here I
was curious as if we were gonna see him
yeah you know Chris Messina
we definitely got some Rosie Perez we
got Rosie toy yeah hey man give Rosie
the spotlight yeah I feel like there's
there's got to be some type of linkage
it's gonna occur between black mask and
Cassandra Cain because that's somehow I
don't really set up I don't how I'm a
bad girl
possibly leaden yeah doesn't make sense
I'm excited for a Harley Quinn solo
movie birds-of-prey see oh yeah I know
let's just wait for the movie I'm feel
like because it's probably so late into
marketing that they're probably focused
really just honing and on what people do
love from Suicide Squad and do love
Harley Quinn they're familiar with her
and they're not taking the time just yet
to really promote their new characters
we're when they are making our footing
the solid let's just lead with that we
absolutely no worries
alright guys well what did you think of
this birds-of-prey trailer does it
instill faith in you do you think of
this movie will knock it out the
park comment below you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we got a YouTube video
up you can check us out on patreon over
there we do weekly Q&A s TV show
reactions stream along sync up with us
but then we also have the option for
many shows where we have reaction
highlights included so you don't have to
worry about that at all he does music
video coverage weekly I want to end this
with a page of the day shout out to a
man named scuba Steve apparently we
missed your shoutout for the month of
September so you're gonna kick off
October I'm sorry about that man you
know I'm constantly shining out people
who are not messaging me back here you
are an active participant
we were just super neglectful I
apologize on Jon's behalf yeah so all
blame goes to John for any mistakes that
ever occur in the channel that's just
the way I roll it's not abusive it's
just the way it is I love you buddy and
because of this error when you pass away
you will be blessed with three hot girls
to keep you company in heaven forever a
wonderful block girl who will scream
beautiful things into your ear a hot
sexy vigilante of sorts of Sicilian
heritage okay and then a girl who likes
to dress up like a clown just to keep
you company entertained while you're
getting it on with the other two oh yeah
maybe with a psychology background just
a thought putting our tissa patient